these days if you say something shitty
on the internet it's a matter of
when not if it gets leaked this time
around
homophobic and racist discord messages
derailed the career of a streamer named
for conor
while also roping in ms kiff one of the
biggest names on twitch
but before twitch had time to do
anything
for conor cop to everything on stream
and said he was taking a break
from streaming
[Music]
all right guys it is that time again
where i ask you to scroll down and
subscribe to the channel we're
almost at 2 million subscribers and we
need your help to get there
while you're at it hit that notification
bell so you never miss a video or a
don't at me
ever again so for conor is a twitch
streamer who first gained popularity
after beating the human thumb himself
tyler1
in a 1v1 back in 2018. a million
different ways i can win this game right
here i'm thinking about which one i want
you with quiets well you still have kick
so i'm kind of worried
about that
oh you're a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] that's fine
how
wait what how oh
honestly wasn't even impressive hey real
clear that was not impressive
skipping ahead to august 2020 four conor
spiked again
in popularity after catching the among
us wave on twitch and playing with guys
like ms kiff train wrecks and xqc
he even started hanging out at the otk
house where ms
kiff esfan and asmogold live but now
almost half a year later four conor is
back in the news
after his discord chat logs leaked which
appear to include homophobic
racist and transphobic comments made all
the way from 2018
through august of 2020. now we don't
know who leaked these
logs but soon after they made their way
online the responses started rolling in
tyler1's girlfriend michaela posted a
twitlonger explaining her experiences
with 4connor
she said that she was in the server when
he made a lot of his
jokes and that she apologizes for not
speaking up at the
time and calling him out for it quote i
never spoke up during this
and yes i should have and i'm fully
admitting that
there really isn't any excuse here i was
wrong not to do so
i was edgy at that time and most of you
know this by now
i have learned from my past behavior
hence why i don't surround myself with
that type of behavior anymore
nor do i even go on discord much to
begin with end quote
from there train wrecks tweeted out a
vague tweet that people connected to
four conor and criticized him for
once he realized people thought he was
tweeting about four conor he deleted
that tweet and responded on stream
when i made that and that [ __ ] went
viral it's like people they're like so
many haters waiting
they like wanted them to like look bad
so they could like make themselves feel
better my tweet was about that
but then as soon as people let me know
that people thought i was referring to
the connor situation
i just can delete that [ __ ] i don't want
to deal with it most dreamers we've seen
either they say nothing at all
or they come live and say some other
stuff i think i think he knew how
how bad it was and it was bad right
nmp lol or nick and his girlfriend
melena who were both
friends with ms kiff both addressed this
situation on stream
esfan who lives with miz kiff addressed
the controversy and even hassan weighed
in once he went live
the n word with a hard r you drop that
very likely you're a racist person you
can send
memes like that back and forth you're
you're very likely race person
but as soon as you start like getting
anti-asian and [ __ ] you're like oh
you're
you're [ __ ] clint eastwood style
racist like what the [ __ ] is this
like what did you watch gran torino and
take [ __ ] notes like what are you
doing
but the biggest and most intense
response came from ms kiff himself
just a day after he told four conor they
would figure out a way for him to move
in ms kim's straight up banned him from
ever coming to his home
again a lot of you guys have probably
seen if not all of you guys
have probably seen the uh
the logs of for conor over the past few
years
and i am going to let you know
that i have made the decision myself
i've talked about it to conor
and connor is no longer allowed at my
house
ever again ms kiff stated that to him
there's a difference between being into
edgy comedy
and just making plain racist homophobic
or transphobic comments
he even talked about his own history
with this type of humor
and how he learned and grew from that
type of behavior over the years
there is being edgy and
i know people who have been edgy
including myself i will not never deny
my edginess
i was an edgy person and you can learn
from it
but some of these logs are way too
recent for me to be
you know some logs are very recent
some just over a year old and
it's not even just a little bit it's a
lot what he didn't address though
was a different conversation that leaked
online which appears to show
ms kipp saying the n-word around the
same time that four conor was making his
jokes now to be clear we don't know who
leaked the four conor chat logs or the
miz kiff conversation
in that same screenshot ms kiff does say
new year new me
implying that he's moved on from his
more edgier behavior
and when someone from hassan's chat
called out ms kitt for being
hypocritical since he allegedly said
similar things in the past
hassan defended him biscuit is just like
this fort connor guy he's just better at
hiding it he also recorded a girl having
a mental
okay so here's the thing i'm gonna say
about miss kiff i don't know his
background i don't know what
he did in the past but from all of the
interactions i've had with miss give
and i talk to him from time to time he
is not like this
at all he might have been a total
[ __ ] [ __ ] back in the day
but from what i've seen uh either as a
consequence of his success on twitch or
because he like truly uh grew up a
little bit
and uh and and started to get better he
doesn't seem
to be like this all okay all of this
including for conor's apology which
we'll get to in just a second
happened on the same day february 20th
now later that same day after all the
responses had rolled in
and the internet had digested some of
the pretty horrible [ __ ] for conor had
said he jumped on stream to address it
it's not who i am
it is who i was right um
i was never racist i was never
transphobic i was never homophobic
it was all in my head it was all jokes i
never meant
any serious harm to anybody's mentals
but what i said was very bad
and at the end of the day i was
being racist i was being transphobic i
was being homophobic i was
being anti-semitic his apology exploded
on the livestream failed subreddit with
some of his clips being viewed hundreds
of thousands of times
from there four conor announced that
he'd be stepping away from streaming
for undetermined amount of time um i'm
gonna be gone for a long time i think
[Music]
but i'll still be watching
i've made way too many friends
what i care about through twitch
to just drop it all now what's
interesting here is that twitch has yet
to say
anything or pass down any sort of ban
and while that does make sense since
it didn't happen on twitch that hasn't
stopped twitch from taking action in the
past
back when streamer jenna had her racist
homophobic and transphobic messages
leaked
she addressed the controversy on stream
and twitch eventually stepped in
and removed her partnership status on
the platform which basically means she
had
all of the privileges that big streamers
get stripped away from her
we covered that situation at the time
while all of this was unfolding
jenna continued her stream and began
apologizing for the things she said in
the past on discord
i'm sorry for anyone's feelings you're
right yeah and i'm sorry that i'm a
[ __ ] up and i'm sorry that i'm a
stupid girl and i'm sorry that i make
mistakes and i'm sorry that i do stupid
things and i'm sorry i said
stupid things and i'm sorry that i'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like i
i'm supposed to say on the flip side of
that was the recent call me carson
controversy
with the popular streamer stepping away
from twitch after discord messages of
him talking to underage fans
leaked back in january in that instance
twitch didn't do much of
anything at all these allegations date
back months and predictably they set the
internet on fire when they first
surfaced
friends are posting statements less than
right and as of publication
carson hasn't said a word now it's no
secret that twitch is wildly
inconsistent when it comes to following
its terms of service
or handing down bans but i do wonder has
this just not hit twitch's radar yet and
it's only a matter of time
or are there mitigating circumstances
that would cause them to not
act on this so would i be surprised if 4
conor made a comeback and started
streaming again after a few months away
honestly if twitch doesn't ban him first
no
not at all but before twitch had any
time to do
anything for conor cop to everything on
stream
stop it get some help you think there's
somebody in your building that like
like listens to these every day oh
guaranteed guaranteed there's somebody
like
honey the guy next door is a [ __ ]
psycho
like you know i just want to know if
like if there's someone who's like the
guy next door is talking about twitch
streamers again
100 my neighbors think i'm a [ __ ]
weirdo dude
absolutely a [ __ ] weirdo they would
not be wrong you know